- [Instructor] What I
wanna do in this video
is to create a simple
spreadsheet to help us understand
why if R greater than G,
why that might lead to more
and more of national income
going to the owners of
capital as opposed to labor.
So let's just say R is 3%,
we can change that assumption later.
So that's the return on
capital that we're assuming.
We're assuming it's just going to be fixed
at that constant rate
and let's say that economic growth is 2%.
So we're assuming it's an area
where R is greater than G.
Now in this column let me write the years.
There's Year One, Year
Two, and then we would go.
Let's see, maybe we can go up to Year,
let's go to Year 15 just for good measure.
Now we could think about
what our national capital is
or I could say Total Capital.
So the capital in our economy.
Now we'd also want to think
about the national income.
So we could view this as
the output of the economy.
National income.
And now we could think about
the split of the income
between capital and labor.
So income to capital and income to labor.
And now let's just think
about percentage of total.
So capital as percent of total.
So let's come up with some
assumptions right over here.
So let's say that our aggregate capital
and I'm just gonna throw
out a random number here.
Let's say it's 4,000
and if we're talking
about millions of dollars,
then this would be four trillion dollars,
but I'm being currency
agnostic right over here.
So let's just say it's 4,000.
It could be, this could,
if it was in millions
this would be four trillion,
but let's just say 4,000 for now.
And let's say our national income is 1,000
and we've seen charts already
that, at least for the U.S.,
capital, the national
capital as a percentage of
national income has
been about 400 or 500%.
It's kind of oscillated in that range.
So it's been about four or
five times national income.
So this is kind of a
not unreasonable ratio.
And now what's the income
to the owners of capital?
Well we're saying the
return on capital is 3%.
So this is going to be equal to
this 3%, I'm gonna press F4
to put those dollar signs
and we'll see why that's valuable.
It'll make sure that we
stay referenced to that cell
as we drag this down later on.
It's going to be that times,
times the amount of capital
that we have in the economy.
So it's going to be 120
and notice, I had the
dollar signs on the B1
because I always wanna refer to this,
but I didn't put the
dollar signs on the B5
because as I drag this down
I always want this cell,
say that when I drag it down here,
I want it to refer to that same 3%.
So that's why I kind of anchored it there
with the dollar signs,
but I want it to be times
the capital in that row.
So we'll see how that happens in a second.
Now what's the income to labor?
Well it's gonna be what's left over.
National income minus
the income to capital
and then capital as a percentage of total?
The income to capital is a
percentage of total income,
well that's just going to be equal to,
I can select income to capital, D5,
divided by, divided by national income
and so it's 12%.
And we're also going to
assume that every year
that income to capital all
gets reinvested as capital.
So it doesn't get consumed in some way.
So, then Year Two the capital
that we start off with
is going to be the capital from last year
plus the new income to capital.
That capital, that income
to capital's going to get
reinvested as capital
is just going to be my assumption there.
And national income,
well we know its growth.
It's going to be the previous
year's national income
plus, I guess we could say times,
times one plus this number,
plus our economic growth.
So there and I'll press F4
because I keep, I wanna
stay referencing that.
And so notice, we grew by 2%
and then these two over here.
Actually all three of these over here
we can just drag down.
And now hopefully you see
the value of what I did
when I put the dollar signs here
because now when I dragged it down,
this is still referring to B1
'cause it had the dollar signs there.
So it's taking the 3% times B6.
So B6 is this.
So it's looking at the right,
at the B column,
but in its row now.
That's what's one of
the really useful things
about spreadsheets
and actually this
column, let me make this.
Let me make this a percentage
just so it becomes a little bit cleaner.
Okay, there you go.
And then we can just keep on going.
So let's just keep on going down
and what do we get?
And actually let me get rid of
some of the decimal places here.
It's making a little bit messy.
So, let me.
So, there you go.
That actually makes it
a little bit cleaner.
And so what do we have going on over here?
Well we see that when R
is a fixed rate of return
on capital that is greater than growth,
we see that capital,
the income going to
capital as a percentage
of the total national
income is increasing.
Now, this could be used
as a proxy for inequality
because as we've said before
capital does tend to
be concentrated amongst
the upper percentile, decile, quartile,
however you want to define it,
but once again this is just a proxy.
And the other thing you
have to keep in mind is
inequality is a natural by-product of
a capitalistic market economy.
And even though more
and more of the income
is going to the owners of capital,
the labor, the income going to labor,
is also increasing.
Now that by itself doesn't necessarily say
it's a good thing.
For example, if the
population were increasing
faster than this
then the income to labor
divided by the population,
which would be kind of the
per capita income to labor.
A kind of a proxy for how
much the individual person
working is making,
then if that, even if this is going up
but the population is
growing faster than that
that might not be a good thing
because that means per
capita income might not be
where it needs to be.
But if we assume the population is stable
or it's not growing as fast as this,
even though we see inequality
or at least this measure
of inequality going up,
more and more of the
income is going to capital.
These people still,
still might be better off
in this reality.
But to kind of test the
sensitivity of this model
that we've created,
we can actually try different things.
So if the return on
capital is much larger,
say it's 5%, we see that the disparity,
the disparity becomes much
much more significant.
And let's say if it was 10%,
now you see a situation that
could get not so pleasant.
'Cause in this situation,
and this is a fairly extreme situation
we have right over here,
now all of a sudden the income to labor
and not even on per capita terms,
is actually decreasing.
So it really does matter a lot
where these two numbers are,
but of course, if economic
growth was also pretty robust
now all of a sudden,
well this is still decreasing,
but if economic growth was 9%,
now all of a sudden this could
be a pretty good scenario
for everyone involved.
You do have,
at least this is kind of a proxy for
increased income to capital
which could be a proxy for inequality,
but maybe the economy
is growing fast enough
that everyone is benefiting.
So I encourage you to either
build a model like this
or I'll give you the link
to this model as well
and play with these numbers.
And just try to get a
better understanding for
if we assumed R and G were constant
and we made some assumptions about
starting capital and national income,
how that ends up breaking down as we go
further and further into the future.